e
right
what's your name the Russia company girl
I don't want to call you the Russia
company what's your name again what's
your name Sophia what's your
name Yara
Yara
sopia
you okay folks
time for the party to
begin I promised you last session that
every session we're going to start the
session with what a start of the class
test about things you won't see till the
session
right you're going to be okay even if
you've not seen it before so today's
class I want to start with this issue of
consistency I mean you think of a
discounted cash flow model think of cash
flows and discount right obviously
but one of the first rules in valuation
is you have to be internally consistent
you tell me how you estimate the cash
flows I'll tell you how to come up with
the discount rate so I'm going to set
the
table I'm going to start a business and
I'm going to raise Equity from you guys
how do I raise Equity maybe I shares to
you or your VCS I raise Equity from you
I'm going to borrow money from you guys
you're a bank and I borrow money from
you I take the capital I start the
business I start generating cash flows
business is working who gets first claim
on the cash
flows they do right interest in
principal payments and if there is
anything left over is there a guarantee
that there'll be something left over not
necessarily but know if there's anything
left over I could choose to give it to
you I could hold it in the company as
cash so you get cash flows from the
business you get cash flows business I
want you to keep your focus on that the
first way to to do
valuation I don't even know what that
meant but I'm afraid to figure it out
meeting audio might not be fully
recorded if it isn't they can watch a
mute session
right so the first way to approach
valuation is you look at everything
through the equity investors eyes so you
guys see the equity investors right what
do you get as cash flows whatever is
left
over and to discount them what do you
need to use a rate of return that
reflects how much risk you see in the
equity for generic terms let's call it
the cost of equity we haven't dealt with
the details but if you have cash flows
to equity you discounted the cost of
equity what do you get as a present
value is the value of
equity now it's a publicly traded
company technically speaking what's you
own only cash flow you get to see the
tangible cash flow is equity
investors what the only thing there it
is publicly traded company Equity
investors what's the only tangible cash
flow you
see somebody I heard somebody
say dividends
right the dividend discount model is a
special case of an equity valuation
model why special because we know
companies don't pay out what they can
all always but if you trust the
dividends you did discount them you
staying with an equity valuation
model but there's another way to do
valuation that requires you to almost
intuitively make a leak which is I
started a business I got capital from
both of you right Equity investors and
lenders I'm going to Value The Firm
which is both of you put together what
does that mean I'm going to look at the
collective cash flows you get from the
business which is not just the cash flow
Equity but what are the cash flows you
get as lenders for
me Interest pay payments principal
payments that Collective cash flow is
called free cash flow to the firm it's a
pre- debt cash flow because lenders now
are part of the process if that is the
cash flow I'm discounting is that cash
flow coming to both of you I can no
longer just use the cost of equity right
which is what you wanted I've got to
bring in what you demanded as a cost
which for a banker is going to be the
interest rate you set the cost of debt
maybe I'll tweak it for some tax
benefits I get when I make interest
payments but I have to Discount the cash
flows at a weighted average of my cost
of equity and the uh and this case the
after tax cost weighted by what how much
money I get from each of you if I get
80% from you and 20% from them I take
away now you've taken a foundations
class you probably some of you have
taken a corporate finance class what is
this weighted average that of cost of
equity and cost of debt what do we call
it in this class let's not call it the
whack it sounds so crude let's call it
the cost of capital right I know the
whack is what the weighted average cost
of capital we love acronyms just the
cost of capital so if you have cash
flows the entire firm the discount rate
has to be the cost of capital so here's
what the consistency rule says if you
have cash flows Equity you cannot
discount them at the cost of capital if
cash flows a firm you cannot discount so
today's class draws on an actual
valuation that was done in the
1970s there's a reason I'm going back to
this
by a banker in an m&a valuation so let
me set the story here the company called
kot it was a copper mining company had a
good year at lots of cash in fact it
accumulated a $600 million cash balance
and the managers were a little nervous
nervous about what what's one of the
things that might make managers nervous
about having a large cash balance in a
company I think that's a good thing
right yeah
that but you invest in something there's
inflation risk it's going to show up as
higher interest rates so that I can
protect myself against it
was it might disappear but that would be
a criminal activity right so what a
Colombian gang breaks in and takes it
away or a drug cartel
yeah yeah that's a
good problem to wrestle with right most
companies don't have enough cash you can
tell where to invest they worried about
something much more immediate which is
yeah then you can give it back to them
they were worried about a hostile
takeover saying why would having a lot
of cash make me easier to take over
because the person taking you over can
use your cash to pay for a portion of
the acquisition so the managers were a
little worried that about it was 20% of
the of the value of the
company so if you have a lot of cash and
you don't have a good use for it and
you're worried about being taken over
then the logical thing to do is give the
cash back to the owners right that
thought never even crossed their minds
what would they do stupid things like
paying off their houses or fixing their
cars you can't allow that to
happen so they took another path you
have a lot of cash you don't have a good
use for it you don't want to give it
back to shareholders what's the
stupidest way to get rid of a lot of
cash do a big acquisition
so they went to First Boston at that
time the leading m&a Bank on Wall Street
and they said we have a lot of cash we
need to spend the cash can you help
us try this out at Blooming D walk in
and I have lots of cash you'll have lots
of sales people around because I think
they work partially on
commission first person no problem we'll
find you a perfect Target and they came
back with the perfect Target how perfect
they found this company called
carendo it's an abrasives company
basically makes sandpaper metallic
abrasives and he said it's a perfect
company and coincidentally the you can
buy it for exactly $600
million this might be pure coincidence
when you tell a banker how much cash you
have to spend the value of a Target
company will magically expand to make
sure the cash
disappears and of course first Boston
leading m&a Bank puts a valuation
because you got to justify paying the
600 billion so this is the cash flow
table it's a very badly done cash flow
table but it's a cash flow table it's
pulled right out of the the the
acquisition and I'll tell you how first
Boston came up with cash flows and I
want you to just remember what we talked
about with consistency because I'm going
to have a singular question about what
discount rate to use in these cash flows
so they're looking at carb randum they
estimate the
revenues the operating income they
subract our interest expenses they came
up with net income then they added
depreciation subtract capex technically
they you know basically they got to a
cash
flow but somewhere in what I just
described I've also told you what kind
of cash flow it is hold on to that
thought because my question is which
discount rate should they use to
Discount these cash flows and I'm going
to give you six different discount rates
only one of them is
right let's see whether you can get that
nailed up so so first you have kott the
acquiring
company carum the target company and
then you have a merge company after you
done right so three different players
you can have a cost of equity and a cost
of cap of each company so let's start
with the Easy Choice first given how I
describe cash flows remember I said
start with Revenue subract get to Opera
income subtract interest expenses maybe
even debt payments come up with the cash
flow what kind of cash flow is that
which is cash flows to in our
terminology cash flows to equity right
so I've made your job simpler in this in
this table which which which column
disappears the cost so basically you can
remove the cost of capital column not
because it's a wrong discount rate but
because of the way you computed cash
flows now I'm going to ask you a
question that half of all m&a Bankers
consistently fail when I do this test so
don't be feel bad about failing if you
fail this might actually allow you to
pass the interview because they don't
know the right answer you give them the
right answer they say no you can't be a
banker whose discount rate should I use
to Discount the cash you know what I
mean by whose should I use the acquiring
company's cost of equity and I'll give
you the logic for it they're raising the
capital and this is cost of equity
they're raising the
equity should I use the target company's
cost of
equity or should I use some combined
companies cost of
equity you think it should be the target
company anybody any acquiring company
people Lisa you think it should be the
acquiring
company if you are a Safe Company then
every risky company is going to look
valuable to you right why because you
have not so first rule in capital
budgeting is the discount rate for a
project should reflect the risk of the
project not the risk of the entity
looking at the project
in fact I think the problem is we call
it cost of capital so in your mind what
do you think that's a cost of raising
this is not what it is it's an
opportunity cost of what you would make
on investments of equivalent
risk it should be the target company's
cost of equity in half of all m&a deals
the acquiring company's discount rate is
used to Value the target
company in in the Catholic Church you
have the sins you can go confess and
it's white fan there are some sins
though I think that are what are they
call cardinal sins you this is beyond
Redemption Beyond confession this is a
sin from which there's no coming back
you saying what's the big deal just a
discount rate here's the big deal they
should have used 16 and a
half% I'll tell you what first person
actually use what's the worst possible
choice you can
make they use the CTIC capath this is
about as far from the right answer as
you can get right and they used to tell
what do you think happen s to the
present value when you use a 10 and a
half% discount rate instead of a 16 and
half% you blow up the present value they
came up with the value of 750 or 800
million that's how they justify paying
million when in fact if you took their
cash flows you took you didn't even
disagree with them and use the right
discount rate you'd have ended up with
like 450 million which case what have
you done you've advised your client to
pay $150 million more than what they
should have and for this you get deal
fees I could have asked my doorman how
much should I pay for the company
probably got better
advice and this is first Boston leading
Investment
Bank I want you to remember this because
there two things that come out of this
you're going to see the people the two
guys who ran first Boston at that time
the co-heads of the m&a department
Called Bruce
waserstein and Joe Pella
this sound familiar remember the first
CL the last class we talked about Lynn
broadcasting and we had Morgan Stanley
on one side and we had Leman Brothers in
the other wasin paral they founded a
boutique mmaa from terrifying word
Boutique now whenever I see it I just
say higher prices that's basically what
goes with Boutique called Wastin parala
and they brought down the practice of
valuation lower than it's ever been they
should have been punished right you know
how they got
punished dressner Bank bought Bruce was
Pella for $2 billion and the actual
press announcement they said it for
their valuation expertise I can't make
up this stuff there's no justice in this
world you can screw up badly and you're
going to rise up the ranks you create a
boutique and somebody pays you $2
billion I want you to remember this page
because you will get intimidated
sometimes because of the names on top of
the page Goldman Sachs did
it the smart people they wouldn't do
stupid things for it's amazing how many
first principal mistakes I see slip
through with big names KKR Goldman Sachs
at the top because people are so caught
up in the mechanics of what they're
doing and in different people doing
different things and deadlines that they
sometimes don't ask that fundamental
question so I would let it rest because
we're going to come back and talk about
acquisition valuation in a lot more
detail when would I ever use the
combined company's cost of cap thr the
question what cash flows do you discard
discount at the combined company's cost
cap it's a merger in this case two
companies going do that but they're two
separate companies what the what's the
magic word that gets thrown around and
merges sometimes that Synergy if there's
truly Synergy it comes to the combined
company that is a cash flow you would
disc discount back at the combined
company's cost of capital but the target
company is the target company the
acquiring compan is the acquiring
company company I can't do what I call
valuation
Alchemy you know you heard of alchemy
Alchemy is something people have tried
for hundreds of years where they tried
to take turn everything into gold it
never works but you see it in banking
I'm going to do alchemy I'm going to
take this terrible company and make it
into valuable Company by using the wrong
companies discount not that
easy so I'm going to set that
aside and go back to the package where
we are we're talking about
discounted cash flow valuation remind
yes go ahead
Sophia but let's pause there why do
companies end up with high cost of
equi they're in a risky business or in a
risky country
right so you see where this is going
right I am Exon Mobile I buy luk oil God
help me if I use Exon Mobile even if I
do everything in dollar terms if I use
xon mobile cost of capital what am I
going to find luk oil is an insane
bargain I lost only a few thousand
dollar on Luke oil they could lose
billions if they tried and it happens
all the time people by Emerging Market
companies development using this stupid
logic right sounds harsh but it is
stupid logic and it leads them into
really bad places yeah
is
right okay let let's pause right there
so it's bad management you're going to
come and fix it you're going to make it
a better run company unfortunately when
you fix bad management good management
the effect on risk is actually minor
maybe you can affect the debt ratio it's
really a cash flow effect
that's called value of control so that's
what the you pay for when you pay for
control and if you that's what you're
paying for the question I'm going to ask
is who's going to do the hard work of
fixing this company you are right the
acquiring company why are you paying it
to the Target company Render unto them
that which is theirs and here you seem
to be giving away the store for hard
work you're going to put in we I mean so
I these a good question because we're
going to this is the heart of m&a
valuation value of control value of
synergy we'll come back and talk about
it but we're already starting that
process so does anybody remember what a
discounted cash flow what do what do we
trying to do in discounted cash flow
valuation we're trying to
estimate of the cash flows the intrinsic
value of an asset and we're hoping to
make money because we got the intrinsic
value right price will adjust but we
talked about the limitations right you
can find a market mistake you can buy it
and then what's that last phase there's
got to be a correction and that's out of
your control so if you look at the
disadvantages of discounted cash flow
valuation a lot of assumptions to make
you could find everything overv Valu not
be able to buy things then you ask who
should use discounted cash flow
valuation I'll set the table the reason
I'm going to expose you to all of the
different ways of putting a number to a
company is I don't want to impose on you
what I think works for me for me I'm a
I'm an investor I value things but you
could be a Trader you could price things
and I want you to BU the end of the
class there is not to do with grades
pick what works for you so with each of
these approaches I'm going to talk about
what would you need for this approach to
work for you so you ready let's start
with when discounted cash flow valuation
works first at the risk of stating the
obvious to do a discounted cash flow
valuation what do you need you need cash
flows if you have an investment that
does not generate cash flows stop using
the word value around
it for the last 15 years the most
commonly asked question I get I get
random emails from random people I'm
sure those people think of don't think
of them as random I don't know them and
I may have this bad I answer everything
because I have no idea whether I know
the person or don't safest thing is to
answer it the most common question I've
been asked is is
Bitcoin
undervalued or is it overvalued and the
answer I give them leaves them
completely dissatisfied I say you can't
value Bitcoin why not there's no cash
flows I can't value Bitcoin not because
it's
crypto but if it's a currency I can't
value US dollar either I can give you an
exchange rate which is a pricing against
other
currencies I can't value it if it's a
collectible I can't value gold either I
can price it you cannot invest in
Bitcoin you can trade it I'm not passing
judgment on you if you buy and sell it
be a good Trader
right so it's usable only if you're
working with assets that that generate
cash
flows what kind of investors can use it
first remember I said markets have to
correct their mistakes and I said
there's no guarantee I'll give you a
consolation price the longer your time
Horizon the greater the chance assuming
you right that the correction will
happen no guarantee even if you have
long time but if you tell me of a
six-month time Horizon my advice to you
is don't do intrinsic valuation not
because you can't value companies but
because you're not giving the market
enough time to correct its mistakes
I'm going to ask you a question do you
have a long time
Horizon we're all we're all trained to
say yes right cuz what's your
alternative shallow short-term person
who wants to be that every portfolio
manager I talk to claims to have a long
time
Horizon but it's a lie because as a
portfolio manager your time Horizon
doesn't matter right what drives your
time Horizon the time Horizon of your
shortest term
client so much of portfolio management
you can tell me have a long time Horizon
but the truth is your time Horizon is 6
months a
year I can see why intrinsic valuation
won't work for you your time Horizon is
too
short saying who has a long time Arizon
very few people I'll give you the
legendary name Warren Buffett
right what is it that allowed Warren
Buffett to have a long time Arizon
what is the what is the vehicle that
Warren Buffett used to
invest
yeah burshire I'm glad you said the
insurance company burshire hatway
because Berkshire haway is one of the
best insurance companies in the US Geico
with a closed end fund and every
insurance company is like that but most
insurance companies the closed in fund
is run by very average
manager but for decades buire had the
way had a really good insurance company
with the best known investor in the
world running their closed dead
fund trust me the story is going
somewhere so Warren Buffett decided what
to invest in for much until 2014 I mean
since 2014 he's turned it over to Todd
Colmes and Ted Wexler his successors but
he pick
stocks who's what money was he investing
what is when insurance companies get
money what is it it's premiums right
from selling life insurance and and what
drives the cash flows from that
Actuarial
tables so they're having a tough time
now with the California fires but that's
what insurance companies try to
do so cash flows are driven by the
Actuarial Table and the Actuarial tables
Don't Panic on
you in 2008 in November Warren Buffett
this is a peak of one of the worst
crisis we've had in the last century
bought two companies in the the same
week Bank of America and Goldman Sachs
bought share you know stakes in the two
companies I mean you go back and read
the news stories about those two
companies in November of 20 in real time
the first response is that is a really
risk and you know what no other
portfolio manager would have been able
to get away doing it because a client in
December said what the heck are you
doing but Buffett was able to invest
because you get the you're saying what
is it every insurance company take
advantage that's just half of the you
still have to Value companies and find
undervalued but if you have a long time
Horizon
nurture you know often you're saying I'm
an individual investor how the heck am I
going to compete with Fidelity and state
stre and all those guys you have an
advantage over them and here's what the
advantage
is they have clients those clients set
the time
Horizons I can't speak for you but I
invest my money
and I have only one person I've got to
get on my side which is my
spouse and I've turned off the the
statements from my brokerage house it's
paperless now so she hasn't asked me
about Invidia this week cuz she doesn't
even know we have Nvidia in our
portfolio and I don't plan to bring her
in saying that is so dishonest sometimes
selectively holding back the truth I'll
talk to her once inidia hits 150 again
you know what we own
Nvidia but now it's done well for us but
this week is going to
be the advantage I have is the only
person I have to essentially con so I
can buy and hold how long as long as my
spouse doesn't find out you got to sell
the damn
thing and I don't plan to let her find
out time Horizon so I want you to look
inward right because this is nothing to
do with you know what other people will
tell you what kind of time Horizon and
when you start your life in
investing you have a really long time
Horizon partly because you're young
you're earning an income you don't plan
to touch it but also partly you have to
worry about the fact is my job so if you
get a secure job and you're 26 this is
prime long-term territory because you
have income coming in you don't need the
cash flows this is when you make the
long-term bets not when you're
63 because mortality will catch up with
you you said 63 have a 50-year Time
Horizon no you don't not unless you plan
to be the oldest person on the face of
the Earth by the time this investment
plays off so that's a lot the second is
wouldn't it be nice if you could act as
the
Catalyst for correction you know what I
mean by that you buy something
undervalued I said go post on Facebook
or on know Twitter nobody listens to you
but would be nice if you could make that
change maybe you can get Mr Beast I
always wanted to meet this guy I mean he
does some the most insane things on the
face of the Earth he's like a 100
million people on
YouTube maybe you can get him to say
Invidia is
cheap maybe the people listen to him
right or roaring kid now you can look up
roaring Kitty you see who I'm talking
about you saying what is this guy
talking about but somebody with a lot of
help I know you and I don't have that
that
help but have you heard of call I can
and Bill
Amman all these activist investors you
know the classic now how does a call I
can targeting happen what does he
do so take Bill acman what does Bill
do oh get forget about the gift give
money first have to make money so let's
talk about the making money half of this
equation before he gets on the board he
does something else how does he get on
the board what gives him the help he
first takes a position in a
company and then does he stay quiet no
he's all over the place he's on CNBC
what is he saying the company's badly
managed it's
undervalued that's what activist
investors have as an advantage is they
can actually engineer the correction if
they have enough pull to
them are you an activist investor well
there's a bit of a problem you need a
few billion to get there so that might
be your end game you're not there yet so
don't do anything stupid like buying
thousand shares of apple and saying I'm
going to make apple change no don't even
they're not even
listening so there are some Investments
some some investors for whom intrinsic
valuation Works let's move on let's talk
about pricing what is it pricing is also
very straightforward you attach a number
to something based on what other people
are paying for similar
things right you could
StubHub you're doing the pricing game
you're not saying what's an intrinsic
value of a seat in section 232 you who
the heck knows and who the heck cares
you want to go to a game you better pay
the price how do you know what the price
is look at all the tickets for sale and
they do you know they help you out right
they break it out into amazing deals
average deals bad deals so they and it's
not rocket science they just compare
prices within a section that that's a
good deal that's
pricing you buy a house remind me again
and how this works or an apartment a
realtor shows you the apartment
then they don't do a DCF in the middle
somewhere no okay so they talk about how
much you have to pay and then they ask
them why they say there are six other
apartments in the neighborhood and this
is real estate is all pricing all the
time you're essentially attaching a
number and what have you done you given
up this faith that there's such a thing
as intrinsic value you saying I who
knows what the intrinsic value is 80% of
people in the market don't believe there
isn't in Val I do but I recognize you'll
never get to see it they're prices
they're
Traders and if you look at the the
ingredients of pricing first you'd like
to get something exactly like what
you're so your house what do you do you
try to find another house just like
yours with just as many bedrooms lot
size is the same in the neighborhood
you're in but often you have to make
compromises right your neighbor your
your your backyard might be smaller you
have one less bedroom but if you could
find a perfectly identical asset and you
know what it's priced at you H irvana
odds are you will never find something
like that in investing so what do you do
you expand the search to come up with
more companies that you claim are just
like yours I know it's a lie you know
it's a lie but we go along right so
you're pricing Microsoft you pull up a
list of 15 companies let me show you 15
companies just like Microsoft what
university do you go to you find these
15 companies or 12 companies like
Invidia you stretch the definition of
identical you call it a peer
group and you ask me to go along for the
right you can already see that stock
pricing is on much weaker ground than
real estate pricing right I can find
houses like yours in what Universe can I
find a stock just like Nvidia or just
like Microsoft but we try the second
problem is when you're comparing prices
per share across companies you're
comparing something that's completely
arbitrary what the most if I Define
expensive as just stock price is high
what's the most expensive stock in the
US we talked about Berkshire haway I
think it was 300,000 400,000 per share
try buying a round lot of Burkshire
haway and if you can pull it off I'd
like to know who you are because you're
going to pay for dinner for the entire
class for the rest of the semester
right and by the same token a penny
stock is cheap right it's stting at a
penny and you can already see that it's
kind of meaningless so what do we do we
divide the price by
something if I divide the price by
earnings I get a p ratio price by book I
get a price to book ratio I take the
value of the firm and divide by Eid
whenever you see a multiple EV to Abid
EV to Sals it's a standardized price you
can see why you so you've got your pure
group with companies that are like mind
but have differences you got the
standardized price and then you get
ready to spend your story about whether
I should buy the stock if you're careful
what do you do you tell me that your
company has higher growth or lower risk
than the pure group and you tell me to
trade at higher multiple this is what
every equity research report is right
there's a multiple there comparables and
there's a story that's what pricing is
and are you assuming that markets make
mistakes with
pricing yes but a different kind of
mistake you're assuming actually markets
are right on average when you price
things because you're drawing your
pricing from everything else but you're
assuming that they make mistakes on
individual companies do you see the
difference in Assumption between this
mistake and the mistake that drove
intrinsic valuation there you make a
mistake you corrected over time here the
mistake is what's called
cross-section you're saying your stock
is cheap relative to these other stocks
and you're hoping the correction happens
and in this case I think the chances of
Correction happening are greater and
quicker than an intrin because it sticks
out if you have a steel company trading
at five times earnings and everybody
else trades at 15 times earnings it
sticks out like a sore thumb right more
likely to be noticed so pricing you can
get away with a much shorter time R
yes course when you buy an index you're
not beating the you're not trying to
beat the market right nobody buys an
index fund to beat the market what do
you buy an index fund to do match the
market if you want to beat the market
and you're buying index funds then I
have questions about where where it's
driving you so the very fact that you're
buying an index fund already gives away
the fact is I don't want to waste the
time trying to beat the market Nobody
Does it anyway it's why it's called
passive investing essentially you're
saying I can't beat the market I'm going
to buy index funds and ETFs to get what
I want and then I'm going to go back and
live the rest of my life actually a much
healthier
lifestyle than agonizing about what
stock to buy what stock to sell what to
home right so that's pricing let's talk
about the advantage of pricing first
you're always going to be closer to the
market when you price things why because
that's how you're setting
numbers and for some people that's a
good thing you're an equity mutual fund
manager
Fidelity you have to hold stocks that's
your job if you come to me and say I did
intrinsic valuation nothing looks cheap
I'm buying nothing you're done you're
fired right Equity mutual fund manager
whether they like it or not what about
equity research
ANS I described at least partially what
they do right they give you 15 companies
and they say put buy and sell implicit
there is a mission your mission is a
pricing Mission I'm saying buy or sell a
buy in an equity research report doesn't
mean the stock is under value just means
that relative to the other 14 stocks
that this person covers this stock looks
cheap so in pricing you're always going
to be okay if that's your job is to hold
equities okay so there'll always be a
portion of stocks that'll be
underpriced that doesn't have to be true
with with
markets and in general pricing requires
a lot less work and a lot less
information which you're going to find
when you price your stocks because I'm
going to make you do it after you've
done the intrinsic valuation say this
was
easy so let's talk about the
disadvantages so you create a portfolio
based on pricing you find underpricing
six even if you're right that they're
underpriced is it possible that your
portfolio could be down
40% think of what underprice basically
means it's you know you f but let's say
they're all
overvalued stock the entire sector drops
yours drops are only 30% everybody else
drops by 50% you are right about it
being
underpriced it's a very different
question you're asking you're not saying
is this a undervalued company you're
saying is it underpriced so you could be
right and end up holding this terrible
portfolio second pricing is built on the
Assumption the market is right on
average so don't you dare bring up
market efficiency as something you're
fighting because you are buying into
market efficiency but in a very
selective way and finally it is true you
require less information but one of the
things I'm going to do when we talk
about multiples and I'm going to take
each of them apart is I'm going to argue
that when you use a multiple whether you
like it or not you're making assumptions
about cash flows growth and risk and I'm
going to make those assumptions explicit
so you don't like making assumptions
about cash flow growth and RIS you know
the only difference between intrinsic
valuation and pricing is in intrinsic
valuation you have to be explicit about
those
assumptions in pricing they're implicit
you pay 50 times revenues for a company
I don't care what you want to tell me
you're assuming High Revenue growth it
is where am I doing that by paying 50
times revenues
so when does pricing work best first it
works best when there are large number
of other assets that are at least like
yours that are being
priced you know Fine Art is Priced Right
a Picasso is priced but a Picasso is
more difficult to
price than a stock and a stock is more
difficult to price than real estate why
not that many picassos around being know
not only do you need a lot of picassos
but they need to be bought and sold
right Collectibles are tough to price
not because we don't know how to price
them but because there's limited data
you have a baseball
card give you an estimate based on the
last transaction but the last
transaction on a Mickey Mantle rookie
card or a Ken griffy Jr rookie card was
three years ago it's kind of stale but I
try my
best second so you need large number of
asset that price and there's got to be
something you can scale it
to the other reason Picasso is are tough
to price is what do you scale it to the
size of the painting I heard that the
monolisa got its own room in the loop I
was extremely unimpressed with the
monolisa because you stand in like 2
hours you go in you're expecting this
big painting right it's this tiny little
thing on the wall say this is what I
waited two hours to
do know the enigmatic smile and this is
like the emperor's new cloes
smile looks really enigmatic then you go
home and check up what does enigmatic
even mean I have no idea but I stood 2
hours I've got to Justified but you
remember about a few years ago another
van go came up and I think Saudi royal
family bought the
vano it was priced at 450 million I
never use the word value when you're
throwing these things around what was it
based on God only knows
it was an ugly looking Mona Lisa that's
basically what it looked like to me but
I'm not an appraiser so I don't know how
you discount for the ugliness scale on a
Mona Lisa pricing scale but pricing is
obviously more difficult when you're
doing stuff like that who does it work
for for short time Horizon are okay so
you're portfolio much of portfolio manag
is pricing they screen for cheap stocks
and they buy its
pricing it's nice if you're judged
against other people who are doing the
same thing do you see why because what
did I say happens in pricing if
everything is overpriced Things Fall
you're down 30% but you know how you
look like a hero if everybody else in
your grouping is down 40% say I dropped
only 30% that's how mutual funds are wck
you look at morning star rankings of
mutual funds they're not measured
against the market they're measured
against other mutual fund managers in
the same
group and remember things can be
underpriced or overpriced right so stay
let's stay with the price game wouldn't
it be nice if you could take advantage
of both underpricing and
overpricing most mutual funds cannot
why they're long only right a Fidelity
mellan Fund can't go sell short most
mutual funds are restricted from
shorting they have to be long only so
who can
go on on both halves underprice over
price a hedge fund if it's truly a hedge
fund this is what you get an addition
into being you can go short a hedge fund
run right can take advantage of both
sides and hope that that way even the
market is wrong and there's a full
correction you're going to be okay
because you're betting on
convergence so if you got to work for a
hedge fund don't even talk about
intrinsic value it really has no play in
this game it's a pricing game you talk
about Quant hedge funds they just
looking for better ways of pricing and
better ways of forecasting Corrections
in pricing
so I actually know in response to can
Bitcoin be valued I actually decided to
write a piece on bitcoin is it a
currency is it a collectible is it an
asset I've kind of given away the game
right basically you can look across
things there are some things that can be
both valued and priced a stock a
bond okay because it has cash flows a
commodity generally can only be priced
you ask me what is an intrinsic value
for oil said I have no idea I could
build some macro model where I look at
the demand for oil and the supply people
have tried it models work terribly
because you all kinds of things you
don't control most Commodities are
priced what happens if you have a
currency well it's currency can only be
priced that's what an exchange rate is
so if you're a good currency you should
have a higher you know your exchange
rate should get better against Bad
currencies so I'm going to pick on some
any believers in Bitcoin I want to put
you on the spot here
nobody wants to admit to being a come on
it's
$100,000 now think of you want to be a
beli okay let's play along
right so the question I would ask with
$100,000 is Bitcoin a good currency
which then means I have to Define what a
good currency is so what is a good
currency what is it what what you what
can you what you do with
it before you get any further why do you
put $20 in your pocket or carrying your
Apple card because you got to buy lunch
first thing with the currencies remember
you have to buy be able you have to
transact with it so good currency is a
medium of
exchange so that's the second is it
holds its value right that's it so the
Swiss rank is a really good currency and
what dimensions
first clearly in Switzerland I can use
it to pay for stuff but if I leave
Switzerland and I come to the US with
Swiss Franks in my pocket I can go into
a bank and get it converted into US
dollars so basically it's it's
convertible and if I put a 100s swis
Franks which I actually did a few years
ago into a pocket of my dress pants I
almost never wear dress pants because I
wear jeans most of the time a year later
I went to put the dress band I put my
hand in my pocket there's 100 Swiss
Franks and I was happened to be in
Switzerland you know what I was able to
buy about the same things that I could
have bought a year ago it held its value
low inflation even a deflation C
Swiss frank is a really good currency
the Indian rup
huh it's a currency inside India but God
help you if you put 10,000 rupees in
your pocket and you go to New York you
walk in New York Bank said can I convert
10,000 rupees it's not freely
convertible and if you leave 1,000
rupees in your pocket for a year you
will buy less than you did last year
because there is inflation for 5
6% but before you complain about the
Indian repeat think about holding
Venezuelan
Boulevard it's a horrifically bad
currency right even in Venezuela people
you'd pay for letters they say can can
you pay with something else other than
currency Because by the time it get hits
my hand it's worth half what it was
before you paid for it and God help you
if you put a th000 or 10,000 Boulevard
in your pocket and forget about for a
year you might as well use it as toilet
paper and it's not even very good toilet
paper a hor so even within fiat currency
so where in that spectrum between the
Swiss frank and the Venezuelan
Boulevard would you put
Bitcoin me rephrase the question when
was the last time anybody in this room
used
Bitcoin on a transaction not did you
trade
anybody here did you use Bitcoin where
did you use
it seven fake IDs okay there's a niche
market out there right the sil cod in in
fake IDs so there's a niche market maybe
use Bitcoin in places where you want to
hide your transactions and nobody can
trace it I'm glad you brought that up
because I asked this question because
sometimes I am asked to talk to these
rooms of Bitcoin Believers I don't know
why they keep asking me back but I say
you know how many and this is Room
everybody claim and most of the people
in the room have never ever used Bitcoin
or transaction and why what holds you
back let's say I went into Starbucks
ordered a venti cappuccino what does it
C like cost like in New York they have a
premium price probably like
$6 I try to pay with Bitcoin course they
don't take it but let's say they did
let's see what happens next right
remember Bitcoin is not in your pocket
it's not in your wallet it's in this
digital whatever nobody knows whether
you have
it so what has to happen for this to
leave my pocket and go into the
Starbucks Bitcoin wallet a Ukrainian
minor has to get on a computer and guess
a nine-digit number comes up with this
convoluted way of doing things but
that's what paranoia will get you
Bitcoin was born and parent you can
trust no one it's an incredibly
inefficient currency
so we judg as a currency it's not a very
good currency so why would I convert it
you know
100,000 dollars for one Bitcoin where am
I going to use
it the other pitch for Bitcoin is a
collective what's the most famous and
long-standing collectible of all time
gold how long has gold been around it
pre predates currencies what makes it
special why did they pick gold as as
opposed to one of the other
elements it's you can mold it into
different things right so that's the
first thing the other is Al it's almost
indestructible it melts and comes back
it's almost it it doesn't rust so
basically there were reasons they pick
God but whatever it is it's become
embedded as and for a long time and
people lost faith in paper currencies
what did they do they bought gold at one
point in time I think a third of all the
gold in the world was in India
because that's what Indians use they
didn't buy real estate they didn't buy
stocks they bought
gold I describe Bitcoin as Millennial
gold why do you do it because you're 25
years old you don't want to look
old and you know that when your parents
Panic they bought gold and you don't
want to be like your parents so you buy
Bitcoin instead I understand it's
Millennial gold and the question is is
it a good collectible what makes for a
good collectible
staying power right there was a time
when beanie babies were Collectibles
there were people actually used to buy
Beanie Babies and bulk put it in I think
they moved out of the house and filled
the house with Beanie Babies because
this was going to be their
pension they're probably homeless right
now because Beanie Babies lost their
value it was a collectible uned it
wasn't because it was a
fad and with Bitcoin you're saying it's
been around 15 years 15 years is not
gold has been around 4,000
years is it a good collectible year to
test run good
collectible is not just scarce scarcity
is just part of the game because Bitcoin
is scarce because you cannot 21 but also
it holds its value during
crisis and Bitcoin fails on that test
every single time every time we' had a
crisis in the last 16 years stocks go
down 30% guess what Bitcoin does it goes
down 50% stocks go up 30% it behaves
like very risky
stock so if you have a Bitcoin
Enthusiast in your family you know the
person I'm talking about he tried invite
not invite that person to Thanksgiving
but he shows up
anyway ask him the question what are you
buying is it a currency is it a
collectible and if it's a currency it's
a bad currency it's a collectible it's
not a very good collectible what are you
paying the 100,000 for and the honest
answer is I have NOA I just think I can
sell it to somebody else at 120,000
which is fine at least we got the honest
answer out so as you look at pricing
remember there are some things that
cannot be valued they can only be
priced along the way we're going to take
a detour and talk about valuing a
company assets businesses in separately
you saying why would I do that because
it's called some of the parts valuation
rather than value the company valueing
pieces like what I can take Coca-Cola
and value each geography that Coca-Cola
is in separately add it all up I can
take a multi- bus company and value each
business separately so I can take let's
take Microsoft I can take the Windows
Office part of the business value it I
can take the cloud the Azure part of the
business which now is about half of
Microsoft's revenues and value it and
then I can take the AI part and value it
maybe less valuable than last Friday and
add
them the techniques I'm going to use are
the same but it requires more
information because you now need
information the piece we'll talk about
when investors might want to do that
especially if their investors want to
break up companies for their
value but it's not a different way of
approaching valuation just a detour so
I'm going to ask you a question and this
question is going to show up in the very
last class as well right now many of you
have never probably fully valued a
company you might not even have priced a
company but based on this very
preliminary description of what you do I
want you to pick if you had to to pick
which of these approaches you would hang
your hat on it's not conclusive because
obviously after you value price the
company I'm going to ask you the
question are you still sticking with
that choice but make this choice there's
no right answer make a choice and save
it and the fifth the last week of class
I'm going to ask you the same question I
want to think about why you've used my
change now as I said there is this side
story where sometimes a a business or an
asset gets its cash flows with the cash
flows are contingent on something
happening I know you've probably done
options in foundations right even if you
having options have some very unique
features first is their leeches they
derive their value from something else
an option can't live on its own there's
got to be an underlying asset and the
cash flows are contingent on something
happening the way this shows up is in a
paay off diagram so if you see options
that the pairof diagram is fairly unique
and as you look at this payoff diagram
it'll give you some insight into why
classifying something as an option
changes your perspective on if you have
a call option you're betting on stock a
price going up if the price goes up you
collect the money but if it doesn't you
lose what you paid for the call option
if you have a put option your Bing on
prices going down and if that happens
you make a lot of money if you don't you
lose what you paid key word is if you
lose you lo you lose what you pay you've
limited losses and potentially unlimited
profits you know what that does it makes
risk your
ally when you invest in options in what
sense what's what when we talk about
risk are you guys more worried about
downside risk or upside
risk do any of you awakens I'm really
scared my stock might double I don't
think anybody stays awake at night
saying my stock might double they're
worried about the risk you worry about
is downside risk right but and what have
I done in an option I put a limit on
what so with options the minute you
think of an asset as as an option you
want high risk right so we're going to
talk about options and there are listed
options we're going to spend no time in
this space there's an options class you
can do warrants and options and
convertible
bonds this class the options I'm going
to talk about are business options I'm
going to argue that if you have equity
in a deeply troubled firm what does a
deeply troubled firm do walk on the
street mut to itself that's part of it
but deeply troubled firms have negative
earnings have a lot of debt and you have
Equity The Firm you said why would I
have Equity maybe you got there by
accident this firm did not used to be a
trouble firm you bought when it was a
healthy firm now it's become deeply
troubled I'm going to argue that this
Equity is really more like an option why
you're underwater anyway what difference
does it make whether you're drowning 10
ft or 30 feet right at this stage you're
saying give me risk maybe that'll bring
me back so we're going to talk about
Equity deeply trouble firms we're also
going to talk about natural resource
companies
all companies where does the optionality
come from when you value a natural
resource company you take existing
prices you bring them in you do the
right things but the thing you don't
control is that price can change so you
can have a company whose reserves are
not viable today but could become viable
you have an option every oil company
with a discounted cash flow model is
going to be undervalued because you're
not capturing the optionality we're
going to talk about how to capture that
optionality if
you're a technology company and own a
pattern the pattern is not viable
today and ask you would you give me that
pattern your first response worth
nothing what you you take it be very
careful because it has an exclusive
right and that exclusive right could
become valuable you hold on to an option
so we're going to talk about real
options that's what these are as we go
through the class towards the second
half of the class but the advantage of
option pricing is now you can put a
number on things you give up on right
many deeply troubled companies you try
valuing with an intrinsic valuation you
conclude the equity is worth nothing you
try pricing the equity is worth nothing
but people are paying for the equity and
why are they doing it only way you can
get there is with an option pricing
model and more than anything else even
if you never put a number on an option
just recognizing when something becomes
an option changes the way you think
about
risk so that's the advantage the
disadvantage is many of the option
pricing models we have and you might
have seen the black show model I want to
ask you do you remember the black schs
model but you've seen it right the model
that flash by making use all those
unusable buttons on your calculator e to
the X log X all of those showed up
that's why we do the black shoulders to
make you use those buttons right those
models were built for short-term options
on traded
stocks we're going to use those models
value a patent you're now talking about
a 15E option and something that's not
traded you're going to be bending and
breaking those
rules so I'm not going to tell you these
option pricing models work really well
because they're going to get
stretched and to the extent that you get
your value from an underlying asset that
underlying asset if it we can't get a
price getting the option value is going
to be difficult difficult what's the
underlying asset in a patter that you
can develop it into a commercial product
and get cash flows on it right it's not
traded out there you got to estimate
layers of estimation on top of other
layers of
estimation so I wanted to keep that
perspective intrinsic valuation pricing
options everything falls into those
three buckets and be at for the moment
don't shut off any doors don't say I
will never do pricing I'm a value person
I price companies all the time I make my
decisions based on value but I still
price them why because I live in a
pricing world I need to understand how
trade think because that's how I make
money the Traders change their mind it
behooves you even if you're a True
Believer in one or the other to
understand how the other approaches work
so I'm going to start on the first
valuation
packet and at least gets let's get the
process rolling so this packet is going
to take us almost halfway through this
class it's going to be the intrinsic
value packet and again let the risk of
repeating myself if you think think
about the essence of intrinsic value the
present value the expected cash flows
right you need expected cash flows you
need discount rate so in intrinsic
valuation you're trying to come up with
the present value the cash flows and
saying that's my intrinsic
value this is not high level math it's
an equation and in fact there are two
forms you will see for the equation the
first form is the one that you see in
class I'm going to give you a second
variation that you might not see that's
completely okay and we'll talk about why
it doesn't show up as much in the first
one here's what you do you estimate the
expected cash flows on the asset what is
it require you to think about all the
possible scenarios you work them through
you come up with the expected cash flows
expect and you discount those expected
cash flows at a risk adjusted discount
rate say how do we measure for risk that
will come these are the details expected
that's your first version there's the
second
version the second version
rather than use expected cash flows use
what are called certainty equivalent
cash flows you said what the heck are
those you seen this uh TV show let's
make a deal with hoe
Mandel I watch a lot of crap TV this
happens to be one of the shows I watch
and here's how the show works right
you're a contestant it's a game show so
there'll be suitcases up so imagine
you're seeing suitcases and suitcases
will have different amounts of money
let's make this game really simple
there's a two suitcases one with a
million dollars and one with nothing in
it you don't know which one is
which and you come up to the front so
you're going to be you want to be y you
you're going to be my contestant I'm
going to be ho
mandal so million dollars in one
suitcase zero what is the expected value
purely
statistically half of that 500,000
here's how the game works I offer you
cash instead of taking that
offer so U if I offered you
200,000 would you be willing to take the
cash and not make that
bet it's a question right if you're risk
ofs say I'll take
200,000 as you get closer and closer to
500,000 you're telling me whether you're
if you're risk neutral you say you'll
say I want 500,000 but the truth is that
there's risk here you might not get the
million doll
suitcase if you watch Let's Make a Deal
you're watching certainty equivalence so
because the contestant say I'll take 400
,000 they took a certain equivalent
$400,000 in the pocket instead of taking
this
gamp how the heck am I going to use this
in malion companies I come to you with
the expected cash flows in Coca-Cola and
I'll be hoe Mandel and said if I could
give you guaranteed cash flows instead
of these expected cash flows what would
you want and you say know I'll take a
haircut and these 10% how much of a
haircut will depend on how risk AE you
are and once you've done that you've got
certainty equivalent cash flows and once
you do that remember you've adjusted the
cash flows now for the risk they
discount them back
at if I cash flows are risk adjust for
risk I no longer have to adjust my
discount rate for risk I can discount
them at the risk-free rate one of my
problems in this class is people who
listen sometimes to what Warren Buffett
says and act like it's religious
theology right and one of the things
that Warren Buffett has supposedly said
Warren Buffett is like
confucious you can say whatever you want
confucious said that he seems to have
said a lot of things like Yogi be said
that really do you know me when did he
have time to talk say all these things
but supposedly Buffett has said that he
doesn't adjust the discount rate for
risk that he uses a risk free rate and
people you that come into my class and
say Warren Buffett uses the risk free
rate why are you using this beta and
risk adjust discount
what's the answer to that I mean let's
say he does use the risk fre rate what
does he have in the numerator he doesn't
have expected cash flows he has what
what he calls cash flows You Can Count
On which is a way of saying I'm going to
count only the cash flows I feel sure
about and I'm not going to give you the
extra benefit for speculative cash flows
he's in a sense using certain
equivalents without ever trying to do
any any any full adjustment but
it's be careful that you don't end up
doing that and using a risk risk
adjusted discount rate so if you are an
analyst and you start using conserv it
drives me crazy when analyst say I'm
going to use conservative estimates of
the earnings no no no no no no do your
expected estimates and do the risk
because if you use conservative
estimates and then you use the risk
adjusted discount rate your double
counting risk pick your battles right so
I'm going to stop start with what I call
my core page and intrinsic valuation as
you know I do value companies I write
about them in my blog and then I hear
from a lot of
people and I won't say what I hear but
some of it is things I'd prefer not to
hear but usually it's people who
disagree with you I've discovered in
social media people who disagree with
you are more likely to speak up than
people who agree with you so I get that
as part of the so I post you know my
Invidia valuation next Tuesday and I can
almost
promise you that within 24 hours I'm
going to get a couple of thousand people
saying you're
wrong and I say okay it's my money I'll
be wrong with my money you be wrong with
your own money so why are you picking on
me but once in a while there'll be
people so won't even say you're wrong
they'll just go to the insult phase
right off they they skip this whole
thing and their favorite insult is you
academic the don't ever take that as a
compliment you know what the subtext
there is right you're an academic you
work in the theory space you're a
theorist and have to laugh because I
know how little Theory there is in this
class you won't see the theory there it
is that's the theory for the class one
stupid
equation but it's an
insanely
powerful starting
point I forgot to bring what I was
supposed to but let's play this game
anyway might have some money in my
pocket crumpled
up I have a $5 bill right here right I
have to make up an envelope oh no I
actually brought it let's play the game
the way it was meant to be played so let
me up the anti so I want somebody to be
my Guinea Peg you want to be my guinea
pig I'll make you look good don't worry
Okay so here's what I'm going to do have
a $20
bill tell the class that there's nothing
in the envelope right I'm going to put
it in there my sleeves are rolled up I'm
not a magician I'm not going to pull it
how much should you pay for this
envelope don't take too long get you to
I'm glad he said $5 you know the answer
I usually get is right what were you
tell me honestly what were you thinking
of saying you'd pay what did you see me
put in the envelope $20 right most of
the time the answer I get is $20 and if
you pay $20 for an envelope with $20
what do you end up with an envelope
which I stole from somewhere and I've
written all
over cost me absolutely nothing I steal
it from the school reserves all the
time but you're right you know you want
to start your the first rule in
valuation you know the value of
something start your bidding at a lower
number if you have trouble thinking
lower or higher then if future as a
banker but not a future as an investor
but this is an easy asset to Value right
at the end this auction if I had one
we're going to end up at 20 so let's say
we're at $20 and now I'm going to let
you hold this all this neat stuff and
I'll take it back don't worry
yeah I'm going to show you cards and I
want you to read to the classier what
does it say Okay says control I'm going
to put it in the envelope with the
$20 trouble getting this envelope open
it's get ripping so that's okay it's
somebody else's envelope anyway
so you ready remember the value was $20
before the card was put in now it is $20
plus control how much did you pay for
this envelope
now she has no future as a
banker you know why I put the word
control
right any of you worked in m&a when you
value Target company you know what your
hardcoded to do in m&a is to add a 20%
control
premium I actually tried this at Goldman
Sachs for their established m&a people
they were coming back for a re-education
camp I think they asked me to talk to
them I did this and Goldman Sachs Banker
decides he's going to be
clever and he offers me $25 you know
what I did I sold him the
envelope in which case what did he do he
paid $5 for a 3x5 card with the word
control on it you know how much it cost
me to put this together maybe 3 cents
he said but I didn't mean it I said now
that it's your own money you feel the
pain
right control so we're on on our way
here so I put control in let's keep
going what does this Synergy magic okay
let's put that in still $20 plus two
cards control and Synergy can't stop
right now what does it say brand name
marketing persons are doing sumers sols
their brand name in there as
well and since we're doing this what
does it say AI okay I'll put that in as
well less valuable than last week but
it's in there and I could go to town you
know what does it say but before I did
that I first had a China that I crossed
out and then I put in India for 20
years in valuation circles you were
trying to value a company and the number
was not budging all you had to throw
into the conversation is but we're going
to be in China
why a billion people low people I mean
they don't even know what to do with a
billion people the only problem is that
China is not working as well for lots of
different reasons so now it's India
let's face it much as we like to dress
up the India story its strongest suit is
not great man governments and amazing
it's a billion plus people it's tough to
replicate it impossible if if you're
Europe you're not even going to get
there I call these weapons of mass
distraction why because they show up
after you've done the numbers right you
value the company said but what about
control what about Synergy what about AI
what about brand name what about great
management what about China what about
India what about all of
it so here's my first proposition it's
called the it proposition if it does not
affect the cash flows and it does not
affect R can we please stop talking
about
it let's go back what's the value of
control anybody want to try what's the
value of controlling a company what do
you think the value of controlling a
company
is you run the company said the existing
guys right I'm laying the
foundation would you make could you run
the company differently
maybe maybe better maybe you don't like
the way the companies run the value of
control comes from the fact that you
think you can run a company better than
the existing management can you see the
foundation we're going to Value control
later in the class when to Value control
we're going to Value twice once with the
status quo and once with you in place as
a management and if your plans come to
fruition I would expect your value to be
higher that is the value of control you
see the implication of this if you're
buying a company it's already perfectly
managed and perfectly run what should
the value of control be
zero if you have buying a company
that's terribly run awful management
value control could be
100% so can control a value yes not 20%
like the bank of put said what's the
value of synergy what is first what is
synergy please don't give me the 2 plus
2 is five crap that that sometimes kind
it's not 2 plus two is four you know you
can't dress it up it's the two entities
coming together are able to do something
they could not have done as Standalone
entities can I value Synergy I better be
able to otherwise I can't pay for it
later in this class I'm going to take
the inbev Sab Miller Merchant this one
of the great big Brewer the largest
Brewer in the world but and we're going
to Value Synergy but we're going to do
it the right way by estimating the cash
flows the growth and the risk
what's the value of
AI let me what is the value of AI to
Invidia sells chips to build the
architecture it's the only company where
there's a tangible cash flow what is the
value to Microsoft already the hand
waving has to begin right it might be
that they can charge a LinkedIn AI
subscription that's higher than a
LinkedIn subscription we don't
know let's not let people use buzzword
and in in many ways what deep seek did
was healthy because there was a lot of
buzziness about AI people paid premiums
why it's
Ai and I've said some terrible things
about ESG and I don't take any of them
back fact I'll give you my prior in ESG
and I when I asked to describe what I
think about ESG I said this is an
acronym born in
sanctimony nurtured with hypocrisy and
sold with sophistry
and I will leave it at that you can see
you know you can go online check my but
the reason I am so skeptical by is in
2019 I looked at ESG because I was
curious Larry FR keeps telling me Larry
FR of course is black Rock's CEO the ESC
is good for Value I said okay if it's
good for Value it might either show up
in the cash flows or it might show must
show up in the risk so I went item by
item does it increase my growth rate no
does it improve my margins it actually
decreases it does it mean I can reinvest
less no I still have to build the same
factories does it make me less risky not
really so why are we talking about it
because lots of people are making money
this is a great detector to
bring the it proposition next time you
somebody throw something Buzzy into a
conversation sustainability ESG whatever
it is push back sustainable of what
where does it show up that's it
proposition
second proposition is don't be a wish
proposition what does that require about
two weeks into this class you're going
to sit down to do evaluation say this
requires me to look into the future yeah
that's that's it I might be wrong that's
okay you can't let that stop you fight
through those impulses because it's
natural to be worried about being wrong
but it would be okay the third
proposition I called the dur proposition
it's named after my daughter who's now
30 and came about when she was in her
teens we used to have family dinners all
four of my kids were still at home we'd
have family dinners I had the distinct
Misfortune of sitting across the table
from my
daughter so a topical conversation would
come up but I thought i' had something
useful to add I'd open my mouth and my
daughter look across the table said Dad
du the amount of contempt that oozed out
of the door was such that I stopped
talking for a couple of years
the DU proposition is for a special
subset of questions I get about valuing
companies here's how the email will go
I'm valuing a money losing company I
expected to lose money forever what
discounted cash flow model do you think
I can use to get a value for the company
feel like slapping the person around the
face and wake up you have a money losing
company expect to lose money forever
let's get this out of the way how much
should you pay for the company they
should pay you right
you have a company with a bad business
model you can't get blood out of a stone
what's a bad business model is a good
way to end today's class most of you too
young to have been potential customers
for this business called Movie
Pass youve heard of it it's about 10
years ago it's a subscription business
where you paid
$9.99 to movie pass and in return you
could watch as many movies as you wanted
in whichever theater you wanted how much
does a movie cost in New York City now
2014 I'd love to see where the theater
is right it's usually 20 $9.99 a month
you could watch 10 movies and Movie Pass
would I remember looking I say this is
the stupidest business model I've ever
seen how do they get away with it and
then I saw the CEO of the company show
up and
CNBC and then I realized how stupid
people can be and get to the top of an
organization and this is how how he
justified the model he said we charge
$9.99 and he said the average American
goes to one movie a month and the
average movie ticket price is
$7.50 we're actually making $249 a
subscription what's the problem with
this
logic it's a self- selection not the
average American some people like you
know how many movies my son saw last
month 23 movies he works at Disney he
claims this is his job
23 movies he had movie pass he was
bankrupting them
singlehanded so if you have a bad
business walk away from it so start next
session we're going to dig into risk
free rates and risk premiums so I will
leave you there
can